today we're talking about some weekly
wisdom back up in Dr and Pub sub metrics
I'm Mark and welcome to this week in
Cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news Cloud wisdom weekly for
tech companies and startups is a new
blog series we're running this fall to
answer common questions our Tech and
startup customers ask us about how to
build apps faster smarter and cheaper in
this installment Google Cloud big data
and analytics consultant Julianne
explores how to get started using
bigquery effectively head to the blog
for more
backup and Recovery is something
critical that you don't want to worry
about and backup service providers must
deliver efficiency at the workload level
while also supporting a diverse spectrum
of customer environments applications
and use cases that's why we're excited
to announce the availability of Google
Cloud backup and Dr enabling centralized
backup management directly from the
Google Cloud console check out the blog
or your console for more
Pub sub offers a rich set of metrics for
resource and usage monitoring previously
these metrics were like buried treasure
they were useful to understand Pub sub
usage but you had to dig around to find
them that's why we're excited about out
of the box Pub submetrics dashboards
that are available with one click in the
Google Cloud console these dashboards
provide more observability in context
and help you build better Solutions with
Pub sub if you want to read more about
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud